seventy-five years ago the country
erupted in celebration with thousands on
the streets to mark victory in Europe
the royal family were a focal point but
this would also be a rare night of
freedom
Victoria pliers mother Margaret Rhodes
was the Queen's cousin she spent the
night in the crowds with Princess
Elizabeth and Princess Margaret she
couldn't remember a lot of it and so she
asked the Queen and the Queen very
generously gave her lots of information
from her own diary mommy said it was
just the most thrilling exciting and she
always referred to it as a Cinderella
moment to put in Reverse did the conga
threw the Ritz and the look of
disapproval on the sort of matronly
women having their dinners you know was
just brilliant the National Army Museum
still has the uniform that Princess
Elizabeth wore that night with a few
alterations made after the war she only
joined the auxiliary territorial service
for months before war ended but a letter
in their archives shows it wasn't just
because her father was reluctant
which explains that it had to be delayed
because she was where is that mops
so there's a letter here it explains
that due to the mumps sheet that she
because they would have to delay the
training more letters show what a boost
it was for others to see her signing up
I do feel I must try and convey in
humble duty to their Majesties the king
and queen the very great honor all
members of the service feel has been
paid them by Her Royal Highness Princess
Elizabeth Commission in the 80s he only
had a reputation as not being quite as
glamorous as the Navy or or or the a Air
Force it seems crazy but it did have an
effect on people joining up once again
Buckingham Palace and the parks around
here should have been a focus for this
year's celebrations but all that had to
be cancelled because of kovat 19 but
just like her father did 75
five years ago the Queen will still
address the nation with a message
recorded at Windsor Castle it will be a
chance for her to reflect on that time
of celebration but also on the
sacrifices made during what were
formative years for a future Queen and
an entire generation the animals Sky
News
[Music]